now to a quick look at covet numbers 325  new cases were added across the state  in the last day as well as 13 deaths the  state's positivity rate however  continues to drop  it's now at 6.3 percent well the  majority of those new cases and deaths  did come from right here  in clark county and listen to this  researchers say the coronavirus can  potentially survive  on certain clothes for up to three days  a study  at de montfort university in the uk  tested a similar  virus on polyester cotton and polycotton  they say the contagious  the contagious contingency of the virus  lasted on 100 percent  cotton for 24 hours and polycotton for  sips for six hours researchers  did find the virus was eliminated after  being washed  in a washing machine with warmer water